camille bonjour commence par un petit
sondage que ceux d'entre nous qui ont
déjà pris part car la formule eu égard
et lèvent la main
ah ouais ouais pas mal
et maintenant il n'ya d'entre nous la
paire est comprise dans le prix maurice
parker on est beaucoup moindre
et si on apprenait différemment et si au
lieu d'apprendre par coeur avec le texte
on apprenait à et clément en a mis plein
c'est l'histoire que je vais vous
raconter aujourd'hui la jambe a déjà
tant de qui doute qui by design ou là là
encore une illuminée qui va nous parler
de pédagogie l'été prochain lynette
risque assurant que le but est bien de
détrompez vous cette histoire pourrait
bien changer voie de prendre ces bons
coutume les français s'apprêtent il
était une fois l'anglais de quoi je vais
vous enlevez vous quand vous étiez petit
moi quand j'étais petite je voulais tout
expliquer tout le temps tellement
qu'elle s'ancre était assez
insupportable et d'ailleurs
[Musique]
preuve à l'appui nous sommes encore en
été 2008 aux aiguilles de babel on se
réveille de nuit parfaite de bivouac ans
et demi
il fait bon le soleil se lever et moi je
suis tranquille mon train d'expliquer à
ma petite soeur de bison pourquoi le
ciel est bleu mandat et en plus ce
jour-là allemand compris vous la livrons
compris j'avais attendu et très forte
expliqué évocation évidente pour
l'enseignement ça t'en dis ça a été un
vrai moteur
c'est notamment elle qui m'a permis
d'arriver jusque sur la bande l'école
normale supérieure de lyon et puis une
fois la vanesse j'ai découvert mon nom
différent celui de la recherche
alors j'ai fait une thèse en sciences
mais expérimental j'ai grandi dans ma
tête au moins et puis mon envie c'est
transformé j'avais pu rénover
d'expliquer gerland lui permettre aux
gens de comprendre le comprendre par eux
mêmes d'être acteurs de leur savoir au
cours d'un mouvement
j'ai aussi fait une belle rencontre
celle de bach à barbara c'est une amitié
illustratrice didacticiel des contrôles
de métier son métier bras c'est de créer
des images qui est à comprendre
nous voilà donc tout les voeux avec
notre passion pour à la transmission des
savoirs et l'acquisition des
connaissances assez théorique et
passerait femmes tout ça et pourtant en
janvier a bel et bien on est d'aider les
biens de saugrenu on s'occupe et 6
une boxe aux scientifiques pour les
enfants une coque ce qui leur
permettrait de comprendre par romaine le
monde les sciences du monde qui nous
entoure ont une box qui leur permettrait
de manipuler des tracteurs sa com a eu
cette idée de choses nous sont apparues
comme lassé des nombres
si vous voulez que ça marche si vous
voulez que les enfants comprennent
fallait d'abord qu'ils on est en vie et
oui toujours cette envie
logicom moteur d'apprentissage
la deuxième chose qui nous a permis de
dante c'est pour qu'ils comprennent
fallait qu'ils manipulent les enfants
qui peste il fallait vraiment jeu pour
spider savoir qu'ils soient comme je les
dix acteurs de leur savoir alors
concrètement on a développé le concept
suivant le concept d'une box ludique qui
concerne tous les éléments beaucoup
seraient rangés et puis aussi un livret
jour l'argent qu'ils feraient l'objet
alex müller pour avoir testé expérimenté
alors que le livret jeu lui est là pour
le guider le guider dans la
compréhension des phénomènes qu'ils
observent le guidait dans la
construction de son sabre concrètement
ça a donné ça
je vous ferai dans le bug bug c'est une
luciole magique lorsque saison qu'on se
touche là les spéciales mais encore
fallait vérifier qu avec vagues et le
premier livraison des petits illuminer
les enfants pouvaient réussir à
comprendre tout seul les concepts de
base de l'électricité nous voici donc en
juin 2015
on a plus de ses athlètes sur près d'une
centaine d'enfants et là c'était magique
on les a vus s'affairaient à courir
partout pour très rares objets le tester
et comprendre des notions comme celle de
supply ouvert et circuit fermé
l'émotion de conducteurs et d'isolant et
d'autre et les petits maux qui nous ont
laissés je pense qu'ils vont essayer
[Musique]
quoique
pour qu on a commencé à discuter nos box
par la suite on a reçu des photos on a
reçu la vente de liens je vous présente
les gars vous ayez à 5 ans et elle s'est
attachée avec elle lui donne à manger
des paillettes et ce jour traduit faut
dire que beugré assez pratique pour
miranda chasse ou la pêche et les liens
après avoir joué avec bague tout tout le
week-end et des séquelles l'objet de sa
maison permettent aux fesses de blogs de
salut mec est capable d'expliquer que
certains de l'intérieur son conducteur
coincé matériaux les bonhommes
électricité nous les réfutons appelle ça
des électrons peuvent circuler sont
arrêtés et permet d' attaques de
s'éclairer voilà le duo envie et
manipulations fonctionnel et ce qui est
assez rigolo ici c'est que je me suis
rendu compte par la suite que tout ça
s'appelle déjà été théorisé et vérifiés
par des grands noms des grands noms
comme al jean piaget kaffrine
excusez-moi dernier venu car brio elle
s'il est un frère andré giordan et j'en
passe le processus est la participation
consultant si ce n'est plus que la
collection quand elle est tout ça je
l'avais appris par moi même en faisant
en créant sa première botte ces petits
d'illuminer bon si on récapitule on a
cette envie envie comme notre
apprentissage et l'importance de la
manipulation de la mairie fellation pour
comprendre à 3 m c'est bien beau tout ça
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
concrètement est ce que paris compte
celles applicables dans un monde réel au
hasard de l'éducation nationale alors
tout soit bien d'accord
ici c'est d'engager tout présenter une
solution magique
je pense que ce qu'elle existe et on la
connait trés répit longtemps elle serait
déjà appliquée partout
je voudrais juste apporter un éclairage
un peu différent depuis 2014
on assiste en france à l'explosion du
nombre de salades et de la 4g aux
maigres donc sa plainte c'est quoi un
fab lab c'est un lieu dans le cas nous
tous aller gratuitement et dans lequel
on a notre disposition d'un certain
nombre de machines de fabrication des
choses publiques et leur est d'ailleurs
présenté en 3d mais aussi beaucoup plus
simple
une circulaire ou un fer à son état
s'aggrave
c'est aussi un lieu dans lequel il n'y a
pas de sachants dans lequel on est là
tous ensemble pour apprendre ensemble de
manière collaborative
à votre avis que se passe-t-il quand un
enseignant pousse la porte d'un fablab
seul ou avec sa classe à votre avis
que se passe-t-il pour un fab lab robin
se déplace au sein des classes et bien
je vous le dis en demie ça marche ça
marche on voit les enfants expérimentent
et testé et comprendre des concepts
parfois vraiment compliqué on voit aussi
les ados prend le ballet est nettoyée
avant de repartir chez eux
eh ouais layrac bon à lens est le milieu
des tables avec l'éducation nationale ne
sont pas toujours facile à faire
mais ça vous vous rendez vous d'essayer
et de tout faire pour faciliter ces
interactions et ses collaborations
ça vaut vraiment le coup de permettre
aux enseignants de s'approprier la
culture maker pour qu'ils puissent
développer leur propre super d'avoir
comploté riels pédagogiques ou pour
qu'ils puissent l'utiliser directement
en classe pour que cela puisse les aider
à passion de l'origine des enfants on
pourrait par exemple imaginer pour que
cela soit possible que la culture
make-up fasse partie intégrante de la
formation initiale des enseignants ou
même qu'elle fasse partie du concours
d'entrée attendant sagement notre futur
et le futur de nos systèmes éducatifs
les plats tout tracé le futur c'est ce
que nous essayons d'en faire tous
ensemble je vous invite donc à deux
choses premièrement je vous invite à
pousser la barbe dans le sable avec leur
petite soeur mon voisin vos enfants et a
expérimenté tous que c'est tout ce que
cela vous coûtera cédant que deux temps
et puis aussi peut-être compte mémorable
quand vous comme d'un continent et
qu'ils découvriront soin de votre salon
design une magnifique landes télétubbies
que vos enfants ayant fabriqué leur
faveur je vous en êtes aussi la
prochaine fois que vous expliquer
quelque chose à mon enfant à vous
arrêter
ouais arrêtez vous arrêter vous et
demandez vous comment vous pourrez aller
sept enfants à comprendre cette chose
par lui même et je vous promets que ça
changera sa vision du monde ça lui
permettra
j'ai le
[Applaudissements]